Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer: When you sit down to
write something you understand that it's a journey
and for some people it's not about the
destination, it's just the journey.
Film Courage: How do you create
a powerful and meaningful story?
Joston: I think it first has to
be powerful and meaningful to you.
I try to now as I write, if I’m writing something
that I just have to tell, it has to a lot of the
time speak to something maybe that I’m dealing
with myself and I can work through a lot of it
in the script and I think that's why it
wakes me up because it's something that
I’m figuring out that I’m working through
and I’m working through it with characters.
I think it starts there. It has to be important
and impactful for you and from there you can
begin to shape it so that it's something that is
easily digestible for somebody who's maybe not
experiencing the same things as you or they're not
going on that same journey with you so you want to
make it more relatable so that they can certainly
see that journey and take that journey with you
what if someone asked you to write a screenplay
and for hire and it's not a story that necessarily
you tap into but you're being paid
well and you say all right i'll do it
but you just can't relate to the character
to the story to the theme to the tone
funny enough that just happened and ultimately we
long story short we just couldn't work together
that's just what it was oh wow okay the the
story was just something I can't relate to
and the way I would have to be able to tell the
story that other person who was the financier
they didn't they didn't want the story to go
that direction so we were at an impasse and
we both had to say I don't think this is going
to work for either of us because what you want
won't wake me up in the middle of the night that
message is not a message that speaks to me it's
not a it's a throwaway message and I wouldn't
want to create something that and spend months
working on something that I don't believe in
I just I wouldn't want to do that to myself
and I wouldn't want to do that to someone who's
paying me the money to do it I just I think it's
it's a bad idea so yeah that actually happened
to me recently and did fairly soon into your
working with the person that this wasn't going
to work this was going to happen I didn't know
it early enough I allowed us to go down the road
too far and waste a lot of each other's time and
I normally don't consider something to be a waste
of time if I learn a lesson but I think I learned
I think I understood things far sooner and I just
let it drag on because I believed at some point
he would see what I was saying and as he began
to speak with his partners they would see what
I was saying but unfortunately much like
me he didn't have he did have partners but
they were out of the way they didn't
have any influence on the project
so their opinions didn't matter so we're
both people who don't report to anybody
so we both we had to just shake
hands and say it's not going to work
that's fair yeah it's better that you cut
your ties then than actually had it made
and it wasn't exactly what you felt well I
wouldn't have been able to write it I just
I think that when you when you sit down to write
something you understand that it's a journey right
and for some people it's not about the it's not
about the destination it's just the journey but
I’m constantly keeping both in in mind the journey
and the destination journey and the destination
so I know if this is the destination we agreed to
to get to this is the best path to tell the story
and if that doesn't work and I see the
alternative is a inferior version to that
then I have to say I don't think it's gonna click
I don't think it's really gonna click because
that journey won't tell it won't be honest it
won't be honest it's forcing something you know.
I don't want to say that but it's just it becomes
it becomes like you're just pushing constantly
and trying to force something trying to force a
circle in a square hole and you shouldn't do that
when you're writing especially in the beginning
you shouldn't do that when you're developing the
screenplay that's when it's fun and that's when
it's breezy and if you can't see the journey in
a fun and breezy way then it's time to kind of cut
bait don't don't spend so much time working on it
for something that's it's not going to be fruitful
for you in the soul nor from an experience
what are your thoughts on creating a meaningful
story versus one that's commercial I think it all
depends on your goals if your goal is to create
something commercial go for it I think that
there's no shortage of opportunities
to create something commercial
there's no shortage of it because as you can see
that's what's being thrown at most of us all the
time something commercial that has mass appeal
and I think it's superficial I think it's easy
you can take the money and run it's it's
what they call it legal bank robbery
it's if that's your thing I think
that for a lot of people who are not
for people who are driven by
quelling that voice inside
that won't really work I think you're always going
to have to be making something meaningful whether
it's meaningful to you or meaningful to audiences
in general because that's how you that's how you
you feed that thing inside of you right that need
to get that that creativity out you're creating
creating something that means something to you
in that moment if you're constantly if you are
a person who desires to make meaningful
material and you're constantly having
to stuff that down while you make something
commercial you're not living your best life
you're not living your best life and ultimately
that's all we want to do that's all we want to do
as artists is live our best life create stuff and
get it out there and then create something again
and get it out there and for for a great number
of people creating something commercial is great
you you go out there it takes you maybe a
couple weeks of work and it's off because
when it a lot of the times for especially for
the stuff now that's like your marvels and
anything that's Disney related and it's high
concept those guys have a paint by number formula
you can stack all those movies one on top of the
other and they'll hit the same beats all the way
through and that's good that's awesome they know
what their audiences want and those writers have
an easy job they know by this moment this needs
to happen by this moment this needs to happen
if that feeds their soul or their bank
account I say power to them hopefully
it does both hopefully does both but if you
desire to make meaningful content you really
have to get that out even if you're
a writer it's just writing the script
just purging it getting it out of your
system and then you turn around and you
write something commercial but you have to get
out of your system you have to feed that beast.
What do you like about this video?